pharmacies that are vaccinating
americans
more americans will get more
appointments in more convenient
locations
the president also committed to opening
at least 12 more federally run
mass vaccination sites and today we're
announcing
three new sites that will open next week
in addition to the two we announced on
monday in st
louis missouri and gary indiana the
first is in memphis tennessee
at the pipkin building at liberty bowl
memorial stadium
second is in milwaukee wisconsin at the
wisconsin center
and the third is in greenbelt maryland
at the greenbelt metro station
each of these sites is the first
federally run mass vaccination site in
its respective state
and each is capable of administering 3
000 vaccinations a day
i can also report that previously
announced sites in massachusetts
new jersey virginia and washington are
now all open and fully operational
in total we've opened 25 mass
vaccination sites which have a combined
capacity to administer
over 95 000 shots per day
these sites are run by the federal
government in close partnership with
state and local officials
and they're part of our work to
equitably distribute vaccines
and reach communities that have been
hurt the most by the pandemic
through these mass vaccination sites
we've administered more than two million
shots in some of america's most
at risk in underserved communities
more than 60 percent have been
administered to racial minorities
all these efforts are on behalf of one
thing
saving lives we need to keep case
numbers down
so we can save lives and give people the
chance to get vaccinated
in april may and june so we can enter
the summer
on the strongest footing possible
now in the weeks ahead that it will take
to get everyone vaccinated
for all of this effort we need a simple
thing of every governor mayor and local
leader
and that is to heed what the president
is asking in return
simply to maintain or to reinstate
mass mandates and we need every american
to do their part together
we can win this race and save lives
if we're acting on our own we will lose
even more people
correcting together we can defeat this
and with that i'm going to turn it over
to dr wolenski
and then to dr fauci for some important
updates from them
thank you so much andy i'm glad to be
back with all of you today
as per usual i will begin with an
overview of the state of the pandemic
cdc's most recent data show that the
seven day average of new cases is
slightly less than 62
000 cases per day we continue to see an
increase and this is almost a twelve
percent
increase from the seventh day period
prior
hospitalizations also continue to
increase the most recent seven day
average
about 4 900 admissions per day is up
from 6 4 600
admissions per day in a prior 7 day
period and the 7 day average of deaths
remains
slightly above 900 deaths per day
as i said on monday this is a critical
moment in our fight against the pandemic
as we see increases in cases we can't
afford to let our guard
down we are so close
so very close to getting back to the
everyday activities we all miss
so much but no we're not quite there yet
we need to keep taking the mitigation
measures like wearing a mask and social
distancing
as we continue to get more and more
americans vaccinated
every single day since early in the
pandemic
coven 19 has disproportionately affected
certain groups in the united states
particularly blacks hispanic and latino
and native american communities
in mid-february cdc released its
estimates of life expectancy in the
united states
in the first six months of 2020
which showed a profound impact on
communities of color
with a drop in life expectancy of 2.7
years among non-hispanic blacks
and 1.9 years among hispanics
historic and tragic declines in these
populations
today cdc is releasing an mmwr that
provides
additional detail on provisional
mortality in the united states for all
of 2020
with a focus on debts associated with
cover 19.
in 2020 about 3.3 million deaths
occurred in the united states
overall this represents a 16
increase in deaths from 2019.
covid ranked as the third leading cause
of underlying death
underlying cause of death after heart
disease and cancer
with approximately three hundred seventy
eight thousand copic 19 deaths
accounting for roughly 11 of all deaths
in the united states
in 2020. coven 19 deaths
far were highest for older adults and
males and were higher
as we previously saw among american
indian and alaskan natives
hispanics non-black non-hispanic blacks
and non-hispanic native hawaiian and
pacific islander persons
compared to non-hispanic whites in fact
among nearly all of these ethnic and
racial minority groups
the coven 19 related deaths were more
than double the death rate
of non-hispanic white persons sadly
based on the current state of the
pandemic
these impacts have remained in 2021
where we continue to see that
communities of color account for an
outsized portion of these deaths
the data should serve again as a
catalyst for each of us
continue to do our part to drive down
cases and reduce the spread of coca-19
and get
people vaccinated as quickly as possible
i know this is not easy and so many of
us are frustrated with the disruption
this pandemic has had on our everyday
lives
but we can do this as a nation working
together
there is reason to be hopeful because we
now know so much more about this virus
how to stop its spread and we now have
three
historic safe and effective vaccines
that we didn't have
just four months ago and we are
distributing billions of dollars into
communities disproportionately affected
to help mountain the most aggressive
equitable vaccination campaign
of modern times millions more people are
getting vaccinated
every single day this week we will cross
the 100
million people who have received at
least one dose of the copa 19 vaccine in
the united states
a remarkable feat in such a short period
of time
further over 70 percent of people over
age 65
are most vulnerable group have received
at least one vaccine dose
i'm proud that cdc stands with others
leading the way
to scale up our national vaccine effort
as quickly as possible
as the president mentioned on monday
afternoon we are working quickly to
expand our federal retail pharmacy
program
from about 17 000 to 40 000
stores and communities across this
nation to help
everyone have ready access to vaccines
with this expansion and additional
efforts in partnership with fema and
states across the country
we will be able to reach the
administration's goal of making sure
that
90 of americans will be within 5 miles
of a vaccination site by april 19th
and we recognize that five miles is
still too far
for many americans and that is why we
are activating resources such as mobile
units and clinics to those communities
where this is the case to ensure they
can get access to vaccinations
cdc is also excited to partner with the
administration for communities
living to support their efforts to get
older at-risk adults
and those with disabilities vaccinated
this is helping to provide
critical access to coca-19 vaccines to
these individuals
finally i want to briefly share that
today cdc is updating copenhagen
guidance for adult day services
centers these centers provide important
social and health services to community
dwelling adults
age 65 and older as well as to adults of
any age living with disability
we know these populations are at high
risk for severe
19 disease and this guidance will help
center administrators and staff protect
themselves
and adults receiving their services by
promoting
and engaging in preventive behaviors
that reduce
coping 19 spread and help maintain
healthy operations and
environments of these facilities you can
find the updated guidance and resources
for center administrators and staff on
the cdc website
it's up to us it's up to all of us to be
part of this
solution thank you for hanging in there
with us for just a little bit longer
and for doing your part to help others
thank you
i'll now turn things over to dr patchy
thank you very much dr wolenski i'd like
to spend
the next couple of minutes talking to
you about the subject
of the potential role of vaccinations
that we are currently giving
and handling the variance that we see
emerging in our society and i have the
first slide
this is a slide which schematically
diagrams the immune response to size
kobe 2.
on the left-hand part of the slide is
what happens when you get acutely
infected
multiple components of the immune
response are operative
antibodies but also something we don't
pay much attention to
and that is the cell-mediated response
of what's called cd4 and cdh cells on
the right-hand part of the slide
is what happens when you recover which
is the state you try to mimic
when you vaccinate an individual in
other words you want to induce
immune memory in the form of antibodies
cd4 and cd8 positive t cells or what we
call cell-mediated immunity
as well as memory d cells okay next
slide
so what i want to talk about in the next
two minutes or three minutes is that the
immune protection
against covert 19 variants which is of
obvious concern to us
when you're vaccinated against a
wild-type
viral strain namely the common virus
in society there are two potential
mechanisms
that protect you against variants one a
high titer of antibody
that although it's specific against the
wild-type
strain it is high enough that there's a
spillover effect
against the variant and the second which
i'd like to emphasize
right now is the t cell response that
although it's specific
against the wild-type strain there's a
considerable degree of cross-reactivity
against the range of variants which is
characteristic of t
cells this slide here shows the high
level of antibody
against a primary boost of the pfizer
vaccine the point i was making a moment
ago
is that that level is so high that even
when you diminish it by multifold
which is the case with the variant you
still have a good degree of protection
next slide but the other thing that we
want to concentrate on
is that and now we're learning more and
more that these cd4 and cd8 cells
are very important in that they cross
react
against a certain viral variants and
they last
for a long time next slide this slide
is in individuals who are actually
infected
showing that immune memory response
lasts
for several months but it also includes
besides
anybody when i mention the very
important
t cells which can help against the
variance
next slide when you look at vaccinated
individuals
as shown on this slide you get t cell
memory response
again against the variance not only
against the virus to which you were
vaccinated against
but as shown in this report against a
number of variants
next slide and finally in a paper
that came out just yesterday it was
shown very clearly
that in individuals who recover from
infection
if you look at their cd4 and cd8
positive t
cells they recognize virtually
all of the variants of concern
so on the final slide next slide getting
back to what i said in the beginning
we are seeing now immune protection
against coven 19 variants
when individuals are vaccinated against
the wild type strain on two mechanisms
the antibody response that has a
spillover effect
as well as the cross reactivity the
bottom line message to everyone is
why it's so important to get vaccinated
because vaccination is not only going to
protect us
against the wild type but it has the
potential
to a greater lesser degree to also
protect against a range of variants
so when vaccination becomes available
get vaccinated
back to you andy thank you that's great
news
uh all right let's take questions
first question we'll go to tamara keith
and npr
thank you thank you so much for taking
my question
uh what uh we're wondering about at npr
today
is um whether there might at some point
and i don't know that this point is yet
but whether at some point there might be
a shift in the allocation of vaccine
doses
based on demand uh rather than simply on
population size if there are
you know pockets of the country where
demand is a little bit more slack and
there are other areas where there's a
lot of demand and not enough supply
whether there might be a calibration
that that you guys are now starting to
consider
that's a great question tamara um and
without signaling anything specific i
want to answer that question
at a high level i think you're exactly
right uh we're going to go through
stages um as we vaccinate higher and
higher
portions of populations where
it will make sense for us to continue to
watch
where vaccines are needed how vaccines
are distributed
the best way to reach more people and
we will be in a situation unlike one
we're familiar with from the last couple
of months
where we have an abundance of vaccines
so i might not think of it
as much as shifting as much as i might
think of making sure
that we're putting enough vaccines in
all the places that they're needed
including doctors offices including
regions including places that might have
been inefficient
to do at the beginning while we had a
surplus so it is absolutely
how you should be thinking about our
approach going forward
uh next question
stephanie baker bloomberg
thank you yes this is a question uh for
dr fauci
can you explain why you decided to issue
a public straight statement
uh questioning the astrazeneca interim
results
um and do you think that they're updated
results will enable them to secure
emergency use
authorization because i think many
countries around the world
that are relying on the astrazeneca
vaccine will be taking their leave from
the fda
even if astro doses are not used in the
us
and then just another quick question
when do you expect the uk variant to
become the dominant variant in the us
thank you well with regard to excuse me
to your first question
i believe you're referring to the nih
statement that followed the letter that
was sent
by the dsmb to
az as well as with a copy to me
i did not have a statement questioning
their data at all i urged them
to make sure that their data was up to
date
in the sense that the the dsmb
had written to them a rather harsh note
saying they did not believe that the
data that was in their press conference
was the most recent updated data
the only statement that we made in our
release was to encourage them to work
closely with the dsmb
to make sure that the data that they put
into their press
con into their press release is the most
update
and accurate data so i didn't question
their data at all
i just urged them to work closely with
the dsmb
and i'm sorry there's your second
question
i think the second question was related
to variance and i can just sort of fill
you in b117
we know from our most recent data is
about 26
of circulating virus right now um we are
looking at it by region
it varies in region from 4 to 36
35 and so we're watching this very
carefully but it is starting to become
the predominant variant
in many u.s regions
i think your final question is was is
asking us to consider
whether the fda was going to grant an
eua
obviously we're going to leave that to
the fda but i'm wondering if dr baucher
you have any additional comments
um given the data that you have seen
relative to the aspergenica uh release
well the data that they made public most
recently
uh indicates to me that this is the good
vaccine that is going to have
a very important role in the global
response to this
outbreak thank you next question
next we'll go to lauren classics at
cqroco
hi thank you yes two questions um first
given the rise in cases and a number of
schools and states that are reopening
how important is it to have a national
testing strategy and when should we
expect to see that and then secondly are
you anticipating any medical supply
chain disruptions stemming from the
backlog in the suez canal
thank you okay
um the first question on schools and
testing uh
dr wolenski do you want to provide some
input into that
yeah um what i will say is we're
watching obviously the cases
by by jurisdiction um our school-based
reopening strategy does look at a
community transmission and is guided
based on community transmission
um we have five mitigation strategies
and of course ancillary mitigation
strategies related to teacher
vaccination and testing as you note
and we're working closely with the
department of ed and others to
to uh input to put forward a national
testing strategy for schools in terms of
um your question about medical supplies
in the suez canal
um we'll we'll get back to you if we
hear differently but
but none that i'm aware of and we didn't
have to send people over to dig
the ship out so we were able to get
people to keep them focused on getting
people vaccinated
let's go to the next question
by the way let me just add one thing
about this tools and the testing before
i forget
um i should remind everybody that last
week we announced 10 billion dollars in
new testing
uh dedicated directly to schools um
so we now have the resources based on
congress and the bill signed by the
president
to be able to vaccinate children on a
weekly basis
uh testing capability is there the
testing resource centers are
are developed and available and the
testing is is quite there so in addition
to what dr olinsky said
next question sharon laffer near new
york times
thank you for taking my question um i
wanted to follow up with dr fauci
um uh what do you think um dr fauci
about the decision yesterday
by the german regulators to restrict the
use of astrazeneca's
vaccine in people under 30 because of a
rise in the
number of cases of unusual blood clots
i think it's sinus vein thrombosis does
that give you fresh concern or
well you know i only have to go back to
the european
medicines agency the ema which again
have made the statement that is their
opinion
that the clotting uh issues that were
seen with the az
the frequency of that was no more than
in the general population
it's not associated with vaccines
so i mean i don't have any further
opinion on that except to say that
you're talking about a situation in the
european union
and the regulatory agency that's
responsible for what goes on in the
european union
feels that that is not an issue that it
is in fact
the same level as you'd expect in the
general population
and let me just pile on to assure the
public of the following
the fda will conduct
a completely thorough analysis of the
application that's submitted in all the
data
from astrazeneca and dr fauci
as he always does will help the public
interpret whatever
comes out of the fta when they review
that data so people should be
very assured that we have the best
regulatory bodies
who study these matters in the world
we'll be looking at this data and the
best scientists in the world
will help people understand whatever
comes out of that so i think we should
wait until
we see what happens with that process
before anybody jumps to cans
next question
jeremy diamond cnn
should we do another question kevin
we'll go to another question it wasn't
letting me unmute but it just said
can you hear me yeah jeremy okay thank
you
um so uh two questions first of all you
said that you expected the b117 variant
to be dominant
in the u.s by the end of march early
april is it now the dominant strain
and how much of the increasing cases do
you attribute to that variant
and then secondly we've heard a lot from
you about the importance of
governors keeping or reinstating mass
mandates
but several of the states experiencing
the worst surges haven't done away with
their mass mandates instead it's been
loosening of other restrictions like
indoor dining and gathering so my
question is
what are you telling states about which
restrictions they should be implementing
and uh why haven't you published uniform
gating criteria
to lay out a road map uh that states
should be following
thank you dr wilsky do you want to take
those
uh yeah and as i mentioned earlier we
now have v197 is uh
26 of the circulating variant across the
united states and it is the predominant
strain in at least
five uh regions of the united states so
we're starting to see it creep up
we do know it's more transmissible
somewhere between 50 and 70 percent more
transmissible than the wild type strain
so to the extent that people are not
practicing those standard mitigation
strategies we do think that more
infections will result because of b117
um we believe that the current
mitigation strategies of masking and
distancing would work
just as well against the current valve
type strain as they do the b117 strain
um i think we've been pretty clear with
regard to our guidance
and and strategies and setting specific
strategies as to
how people can remain safe in these
settings and we continue to articulate
in these practice conferences of others
the importance of masking distancing
not traveling and and decreasing crowds
yeah let me just just reiterate i think
three times a week for the last 10 weeks
dr wolenski has made the same points
over and over and over again because
repetition
is good and it's important people want
to know that they're getting consistent
answers and
consistently three times a week for 10
weeks dr wolinski has said
wear a mask avoid crowds
socially distance and don't travel
unless it's absolutely essential
three times a week for 10 weeks we
repeat that in all our conversations
with governors we repeat that in all our
conversations with local officials
and we're not the only ones saying it
public health officials from departments
and agencies across the country
make the same points so that people who
are
in violation of that are choosing to do
that
they they're not confused about about
where we stand
to your point jeremy uh that's not the
only factor
that drives case growth uh and even
where there are mandates that everyone
um complies by them but they're where
the variants are
at any given time is obviously also
another important factor
next question we're going to squeeze one
more question in
we'll go to uh sikon akban at newark
public radio
hi thank you for taking my question so
new york health health officials
continue to voice concerns about the
b1526 variant you know early studies
suggest this variant was first detected
last november and it now represents a
large proportion of cases in new york
city and new jersey
namely in counties undergoing surges yet
the cdc
still classifies b1526 as a variant of
interest rather than a variant of
concern
i'm wondering what additional evidence
is needed before
b1526 is classified as a variant of
concern
does the cdc plan to release
state-by-state case numbers
on the new york variant rather than just
a rough proportion
and what's the national tally of b1526
cases so far
thank you for that question i'm going to
have to get back to you on the details
on the national tally what i will say is
that there is an
interagency group that looks at these
variants and classifies them and is that
interagency group cdc is a part of that
that
is actually looking at exactly this
question right now
thank you uh thank you all i want to
just take the opportunity
for us to wish everyone the call a happy
holiday season
and a safe holiday season uh thank you
very much
you